[Música]
[Aplausos]
yo voy a empezar preguntándote hace
cuánto tiempo hace cuánto tiempo
que no te arriesgas
hace cuánto tiempo en tu vida ya sea
profesional o estudiantil tú asumes un
riesgo
piensa por favor cuando fue la última
vez que tú sentiste
el cosquilleo en el estómago un poco de
transpiración en las manos porque
estabas haciendo algo completamente
distinto a lo que hace cotidianamente
por favor te invito a que hagan memoria
si te preguntas realmente hace cuánto
tiempo que no haces en tu vida algo algo
realmente arriesgado
la pregunta un poco tiene que ver
no con si te lanzas en parapente de
arriba a cierto
la pregunta no tiene que ver
necesariamente con que te pares acá sino
que la pregunta tiene que ver con lo que
se pregunta muchas de las personas que
tú viste pasar por aquí sí
no por el hecho que estén acá sino por
lo que emprendieron en su vida la
pregunta tiene que ver no es cierto con
cuántas veces al día
tú te arriesgas para hacer tú mismo para
ser tú mismo
y para realmente expresar
para los tuyos el potencial que está en
ti
seguramente tú te conectas temas con
algunos de los ponentes que estuvieron
hoy día acá en la universidad valle del
momboy en este de equis que la
universidad organizó y seguramente te
llegó la imagen del profesor no es
cierto o te llegó a la imagen del mago
no ser todo de maría alejandra con el
ecodiseño sí o de nuestro amigo que nos
habló de ese otro planeta donde están
los seres creativos
seguramente que te conectas temas con
algunos de ellos o de ella pero la
pregunta que yo te hago tú te estás
arriesgando como ellos como ellas para
como decimos nosotros sacar para afuera
todo el potencial
entonces cuando yo me pregunto si tú
vienes de un caminar y por ejemplo
tienes no sé 16 años 18 años mira para
atrás en tu vida cuántas veces te has
arriesgado realmente
si tienes 25 preguntas cuántas veces
para trastes arriesgados realmente
y te vas a encontrar bueno si tienes 38
no voy a seguir para allá porque si no
se empiezan a enojar si pero no viene
nada en particular ok pero si tú si tú
te pones realmente a preguntarte si y
empieza a recordar cuando te has
arriesgado tú te vas a dar cuenta que
son momentos momentos en que tú te has
puesto a hacer cosas que valen la pena
difundir a otros
son son momentos en que tú has dejado de
ser el estudiante que va a clase todos
los días y participas en algo particular
has dejado de ser el profesional que va
al trabajo todos los días y realmente
hacia 'la haces algo que vale la pena
y que vale la que valen las ganas
difundir
seguramente cuando tú te has arriesgado
si no ha pasado a ser también un
profesional que un profesional un
profesor un docente que marca la
diferencia en tu zona en tu familia en
tu estado
entonces bueno a qué se debe que
nosotros no nos arriesguemos tanto
yo quiero compartir con ustedes unas
imágenes primero una cosa que nosotros
tenemos que tener presente y no me
quiero alargar mucho en esto es que
nosotros estamos lo que se llaman la
socia del conocimiento
pero todo nuestro sistema educativo en
todos los países a nivel mundial no
solamente en latinoamerica no solamente
en chile no solamente en venezuela no
solamente en temuco no solamente en
valera está basado en la era industrial
y este es una idea no es mía es de
petersen
qué es lo que él plantea él dice que
todos nosotros entramos cuando entramos
a enseñanza básica si en un sistema de
producción que imita la cadena de
montaje de los autos ford qué significa
eso que primero tomas un primer curso y
luego un segundo curso y luego un tercer
curso y así hasta ahora te acuerdas de
eso es cierto
así es
sí ahora qué pasa si tú sabías la
materia tenía que esperar tenías que ir
junto con el curso no había forma de
adelantar no había forma de pasar
adelante y lo que queda mal es la cadena
de montaje repite si es desechado y yo
te pregunto para los que están en la
universidad quienes de acá son
estudiantes universitarios podrían
adaptar la mano por favor para ubicar y
tenemos una buena concurrencia gracias
yo te quiero preguntar que que vayas a
tu enseñanza básica y recuerde cuantos
de tus compañeros están en la
universidad ahora
cuantos quedaron en el camino cuántos
quedaron fuera de esa cadena montaje
entonces nosotros decimos dónde se va
perdiendo el potencial el potencial se
va perdiendo ya porque a veces nuestro
proceso educativo no es tan bien armado
ahora qué podemos hacer con eso qué
puedes hacer tú con eso primero que nada
puede hacer lo que han hecho alguna de
las personas que se pararon acá qué es
lo que hicieron se pusieron a mirar y
observaron el entorno seguramente muchas
personas habían observado lo que el
profesor observó con su equipo hay
faltan libros en escuelas rurales
pero la respuesta creativa que ellos
dieron pocos la han dado ahora cuando
nosotros hablamos de observación
yo quiero mostrarles dos ejemplos de lo
que puede pasar si tú te pones a tratar
de ser un buen observador el primero y
con esto me voy a meter en algo complejo
tiene que ver con un doctor chileno y su
colega él jimena dávila él se llama
humberto maturana y él hace unos años
atrás en los años 60 se puso a hacer
unas preguntas científicas un poco raras
la gente pensó que se había vuelto loco
porque porque él
les voy a explicar con la teoría o lo
que yo comprendo su teoría
él hizo lo siguiente él se puso a
preguntarse qué significaba el color
nada más unas preguntas sencillas
entonces lo que uno aprende que el color
viene de afuera se refleja cierto si uno
hace esperar un disco se ve blanco si
pasa a través del prisma la luz se
transforma en muchos colores pero inició
un experimento esta es mi versión yo lo
comprendo así él puso a unas palomas
aquí picaran en el color verde es decir
en este color de acá
y ese color verde el color verde puntual
tiene una cierta longitud de onda que yo
la dibujé ahí abajo cierto bueno el
mezclo dos colores y generó otro verde
un verde falso
la paloma
como observa solamente longitudes de
onda debería picar en este verde cierto
y que creen ustedes cuál es la hipótesis
falsa que no debería aplicar aquí porque
un color falso
la paloma no ve el color como nosotros
lo vemos la paloma ve longitudes de onda
adivinen lo que pasó en el experimento
pusieron a las palomas a picar este
color y después lo masticaba
pero cuando ponen a las palomas a picar
en esta sombra de color verde falso
sombra de color del verde las palomas
también pican
entonces dijo no puede ser porque las
palomas no deberían picar porque la
longitud de onda científica nos dice que
este color es falso repitió el
experimento repitió el experimento le
contó el experimento a otro lo volvió a
repetir hasta que llegó a una conclusión
y dijo estoy enfocando el experimento de
manera distinta
y planteo
lo siguiente
las palomas no pican el color
a las palomas pican el nombre del color
ahí viene la pregunta obvia cierto como
sabe la paloma
que el color se llamaba
bueno ahí yo les voy a dejar con esa
inquietud pero
el experimento tiene que ver con eso
y quiero que te quede un poquito en ese
como quebradero de cabeza así que muchos
científicos en el mundo están tratando
de entender esto que yo estoy tratando
de explicar acá las palomas pican porque
este color se llama verde y porque este
color se llama verde
magia cierto
y como saben las palomas
entonces él plantea que que las palomas
aprenden en el lenguaje como los
científicos que esta longitud de onda se
llama verde y que esta longitud de onda
se llama verde
entonces él dice lo siguiente dice no
hay allá afuera algo que nosotros
podamos llamar color verde eso no es
posible
porque nuestro sistema nervioso y ahí
viene la teoría del es cerrado
estructuralmente
y lo único que hace esa longitud de onda
es gatillar
una determinada respuesta nuestra es
decir que nosotros nos inventamos el
verde
entonces así como las palomas
nosotros vemos lo que hemos aprendido a
ver en la sociedad en la que nos criamos
mira qué interesante y nos vemos
lo que nuestros padres no nos han
enseñado a ver
entonces observar no tiene que ver con
que las cosas estén o no allá afuera
sino que tiene que ver con lo que tú
estás capacitado para ver
entonces por este porque sé quién es le
hace una entrevista muy larga en un
libro muy hermoso que se llama del ser
al hacer le pregunta entonces qué es un
color y maturana dice lo que estoy
diciendo el color no es nada externo
sino que sucede al interior del
organismo y que es gatillado por una luz
por ejemplo los esquimales ven una gran
cantidad de tipos de nieve que nosotros
si nosotros vamos no distinguimos
nosotros volvemos blanco vemos un solo
tipo de nieve qué significa eso que
vemos un solo color
pero como los esquimales de nieve porque
han sido enseñados a observar un poco
más
porque traigo este ejemplo a colación
porque lo que tú has tenido ahora en el
tedh es la oportunidad de ampliar tu
visión y comenzar a observar
oportunidades donde otros no ven
observar magia donde otros ven
simplicidad observar oportunidades donde
otros ven niños sin lectura
ahora tú vas a ir a la cuadra y me
gustaría llevar una picota sí y picar la
vereda para que hay un árbol frente a la
a su casa si lo que estamos tratando
antes es que tú mires de manera
diferente
y observé de manera diferente que no te
quedes quieto como estudiante haciendo
lo que te dicen solamente en las
materias hay un mundo allá afuera en que
están pasando un montón de cosas y que
nosotros nos estamos quedando fuera
porque nos estamos quedando en la rutina
por ejemplo una cosa que pasa afuera y
te lo voy a comentar brevemente hace 200
años ocurrió la migración del campo la
ciudad más importante en el mundo que
fue la toda la transformación de europa
de una era agraria a una cita tina aquí
y otra te dibujaron un campo y haya una
ciudad que se ve bien poquito y una
flecha significa que mucha gente emigra
del campo la ciudad tú dices eso ya
ocurrió aquí también está ocurriendo los
dos pueblos pequeños están quedando solo
pero no la mayor migración campo-ciudad
está por realizarse sí y de aquí en 2024
en china 300 millones de personas van a
emigrar del campo a la ciudad
te imaginas la cifra te ayudo
significa que van es un chinito
significa que van a migrar 20 millones
de chinos por año 20 millones de chinos
por año durante de aquí al 2024 van a
migrar del campo la ciudad significa
sino quien de aquí tiene trabajo en
construcción quien tiene constructoras
por allá alguien si no no no
bueno imagínate que hubiera un
constructor significa que tenemos que
construir una ciudad para un millón
seiscientos mil habitantes por mes por
los próximos quince años
qué ciudad tiene un millón 600 mil
habitantes acá
valencia maracaibo imagina que tú eres
parte del equipo que construye esa
ciudad
terminas el sábado de construir tu
ciudad el domingo descansa y el lunes
adivina que empieza a hacer otra ciudad
y el otro mail otra y el otro mes otra
durante 15 años
eso yo no lo puedo decir aquí pero sí
qué significa eso
bueno
qué oportuno y observas lo que yo
observo para ti para mí y para todos
nosotros latinoamérica son nuevas
oportunidades profesionales porque
porque va a faltar mucha gente que ayude
y que coopere en ese país tan distante
para que las cosas se hagan de una
manera determinada de una buena manera
yo sé que este ejemplo te puede sonar
lejano pero piensa tú lo que estábamos
viendo hace un rato cuando el mago nos
hacía magia uno pero qué quiere ver sí y
uno ve que esto es imposible que la niña
transformara el pañuelo rojo lo que
transformó cierto si uno dice cómo
ocurre eso y esto tal vez tú lo ves
lejano pero tiene que ver con lo que
estamos observando
entonces
la invitación que yo les quiero hacer
primero es
a que nosotros armamos miremos la
educación y el aprendizaje de manera
diferente que armemos espacios de
convivencia que no te tomes solamente la
universidad o que no te tomes solamente
el trabajo universitario como vida un
aula y sacar un título eso no tiene
ningún sentido vas a salir no es cierto
a trabajar donde mucha gente va a
trabajar
si tú vas y te tomas la universidad como
una oportunidad vas a salir a aportar al
mundo
segundo pensar que eso te va a provocar
bienestar sí y que ojalá tu profesión
tenga que ver entonces en esta
convivencia humana con el bienestar de
las personas y no necesariamente con el
lucro quiera como decía el mago no
siento el emprender tiene que ver no
solamente con genera el negocio tiene
que ver con generar oportunidades
segundo y es un caracol es que no te
creas el tema del crecimiento
luego conocerte y tener que crear una
tremenda industria y todo sino que
pensar en el molín movimiento 'slow de
hacer las cosas con calma si de comer la
los frutos o vegetales que cultivan en
tu casa en tu huerto si hay todo un
movimiento por caminar lento andar lento
y hacer las cosas con calma yo sé que tú
vas a querer como estudiantes salir de
la universidad y encontrar trabajo
inmediatamente y ganar un buen sueldo
inmediatamente las cosas no suceden así
tú viste un vídeo los ocho pasos del
éxito persistencia pasión perseverancia
tercer lugar que si tú piensas en el
emprendimiento y la creatividad como
estamos viendo acá no piensen en generar
un tremendo programa sino que piensen en
cómo trabaja un artesano
lo que estamos haciendo ahora con este
télex es pensar que cada uno de ustedes
que estaban escuchando puede dar una
ponencia acá sobre qué sobre un aspecto
de su vida sobre algo en lo que está
marcando la diferencia en cualquier área
de actividad sí y eso implica una red de
artesanos una red de artesanos
coordinado como una red de pesca donde
cada parte cita de la red es importante
entonces para cerrar cuál es la
invitación mi invitación en cerrando
este télex y dándole las gracias a la
universidad del momboy por haberme
invitado a participar acá es parar y
reflexionar y mirar realmente si estás
asumiendo un riesgo con lo que estás
haciendo entonces te vuelvo a preguntar
hace cuánto tiempo que no te arriesgas
hace cuánto tiempo que no te arriesgas a
expresar tu potencial muchas gracias
[Aplausos]